The Sun is the most important star in our
galaxy, and at some point, it’s going to
die.
When that happens, it’ll turn into a red
giant, getting so big it’ll swallow Mars,
Mercury, and quite possibly vaporize our own
planet.
Don’t panic yet, we’ve got a billion years
to prepare before the big red comes.
Stars have a life cycle just like us: they
are born, they live, and then they die.During
their lives, stars need to have a strong core,
one that can fuse hydrogen into helium to
make nuclear fusion.
Stars will work their cores for billions of
years.
But eventually, they’ll run out of hydrogen
for their fusion process.
When that happens, the star can't hold up
against gravity and its core will start to
collapse.
The core will get smaller and denser, while
its outer shell expands and cools, giving
a distinctive red hue.
The combination of “cooling” and “expanding”
is where the name red giant comes from.
Red giants are YUGE, reaching sizes of 100
million to 1 billion kilometers in diameter,
or 62 million to 621 million miles.
That’s nearly 1,000 times the size of the
sun.
So when our sun turns into a red giant, life
as we know it will cease to exist.
But there is an upside to this.
When stars morph into red giants, they change
their habitable zone.
The habitable zone is a region with the right
conditions for life.
So as the Sun gets larger and redder, it’s
warmth will extend to the outer reaches of
our solar system.
Making it possible for life to begin on a
whole new planet.